first up this morning texas governor
greg abbott took us on a black hawk
helicopter ride above texas
to view the 1200 plus miles of the texas
border
being breached every single day
smugglers and criminal cartels are the
biggest winners
transporting 2 000 people every 24 hours
in rafts and boats and helping some
through gaps in the unfinished wall
most of the people coming in want to be
apprehended so they can get processed
and eventually assimilate into america
but there is another group that are
criminals who got away
and ended up in the interior of our
country
the governor along with the heads of the
national guard and the department of
public safety
walked me through it all while we toured
from above
there are some people who cross the
border who do want to get apprehended so
they can get processed
and hopefully assimilate the people that
dps arrests
are the people who don't want to be
caught they
are known criminals and they would wind
up back in jail
the white pins here are the donna
facility uh
and there's almost like two different
sections one of these
tents that are nearest to us right now
they were not there two months ago when
i came here two months ago that was just
dirt and then you had those other white
tents on the other side and they were
there when i first came
but you can tell they're all relatively
new the action picks up at night the the
stunning thing for me is that it used to
be that
most of the illegal crossing of the
border
would occur at nighttime but under this
administration
it occurs in high volume during the
daytime have you spoken
with the president the vice president do
they reach out to you
to get an update on things no
in a word no
very different from the prior
administration so this part right here
it was that
intended for wall construction you see
all the
the equipment that yeah this is part of
the wall that was under
construction and they just stopped
you're going to see right up here they
picked it back
up they just didn't connect the two
locations and it was all paid for
it's all paid for the texas border
with mexico is about 250 miles
to be precise i want to say it's 1264.
you can google it
but it
it's just if it were straight-line
desert like in arizona
it'd be one thing this is far more
difficult to patrol and to
protect is all of mexico run by the
cartels or just the border
unfortunately uh the systemic corruption
throughout mexico
that no one's safe they've uh undermined
the rule of law everywhere
and uh there's no place you can get away
from the cartels right now
it's a domestic security threat to them
since the crisis spiked after january
20th of this year
president biden and vice president
harris have yet to visit the border and
the governor has not heard from them
after our black hawk tour texas governor
greg abbott sat down with me for this
exclusive interview
well first about the president not
mentioning the board border in his
state of the union address i think it
shows kenneth
he doesn't care about the border and
they they do not want to resolve
the challenges that we have on the
border but i will tell you this
the first 100 days of the administration
they've been great for the cartels for
the gangs for the human traffickers who
have been
exploiting the border because what
happens is
you have all these young migrants surged
the border and the border patrol
officers are occupied dealing with those
who are searched in
and that is when the cartels and gang
members they're able to
use the open spaces to sneak across
the more high valued people such as
terrorists
such as people with criminal records and
as well as
fentanyl the drugs and things like that
and that's exactly why we have
all of these department of public safety
officers down here because
we are working to for texas to deploy
resources
to secure the border so what kind of a
cost does this represent for the state
of texas because
we're not talking about the cost very
much of this a good point because
this doesn't come free so our state
legislature
they allocate about 800 million dollars
every two years for the state to pay for
this
this year because of the extended time
that we will have the national guard on
the border
it likely will clearly exceed a billion
dollars for the
state to have to secure the united
states of america
so here's our goal we're paying for this
but i want to have texas secure the
border and have the biden administration
pay for it
you know we're going to talk with a.g
paxton later on the show
but he made a point saying texas is a
launch pad
but once they come in through texas
illegals are going all across the
country
drugs are going into the interior of the
country tell me about that because one
border patrol agent told me
that the numbers for fentanyl up 5 000
percent
year over year heroin up four thousand
percent
in terms of drugs seized no you'll have
people in the country
in the mid western part of the northern
part think well
that's a border issue we'll have to
worry about it the border comes to them
every single day because as people cross
the border
they take the gang members will export
the drugs to chicago to new york to
north or south carolina or even up to
washington
state or other places like that and so
every state
is affected by the people who are coming
across the border illegally and that's
exactly why
all of us need to join together in this
process to make sure that we are
securing it so that we are stopping
the drug traffickers and maria the human
traffickers
human trafficking is one of the most
vicious and serious crimes that takes
place across the country
and the way that the people come across
the border is through human trafficking
and then those human traffickers in the
united states that continue that
practice
as they exploit people wherever they may
send them to across the country
the other thing that really struck me
was once they're released after they get
processed once they're released
they get legal status it shows the
president's
president biden's approach to this and
that is to abandon the rule of law
uh what they're supposed to to do is to
detain them
to cite them uh to require that they
show up for a court hearing
and they've even abandoned the practice
of requiring citations and
requiring appearance at courts to show
up and so that does mean
that all you have to do is get across
the border and you can
do anything you want to do and of course
that means it's an abandonment
of the legal immigration laws passed by
the united states congress
why is the biden administration allowing
this what you're asking right now
is the most important question in the
united states that too many people are
not asking
not enough journalists are asking not
enough members of congress are asking
about why the administration is doing
nothing
to stop this from happening and and not
even acknowledging what the consequences
are going to be
to the united states of america because
you mentioned one thing about the cost
and that is the cost that we are
incurring with regard to securing the
border but
we didn't talk about the health care
costs the education costs the law
enforcement costs
all these other costs that will be
incurred not just by texas
but by all of these other states that
the gangs
and the human traffickers eventually go
to and
it seems like the cartels are really
winning and
making big money here someone told me
this week that they're making
400 million dollars monthly
i mean the the numbers because they're
charging four thousand dollars ahead
they're taking 2 000 people a day into
america and depending on where you come
from the numbers are even higher
one guard told me that they apprehended
a group from china
and the group from china told them that
they paid
50 000 ahead and by the way
these were scientists and doctors and
engineers from china
you have to ask why the ccp is sending
these people through the border
obviously they don't want to be noticed
what are they doing when they get here
could be espionage and and so and there
again
uh that this shows the danger of the
blind administration not doing anything
because
we need to debunk if there's anybody out
there who thinks that
these are still just people coming from
mexico or central america
coming here to engage in agriculture
something like that
they're forgetting about the people from
china from iran
from terrorist space nations it could be
espionage so what's your reaction to
what vp
harris said that she wants to send 310
million what all they're planning on
doing but
let's talk about what they're not doing
they're not coming down here to the
border
so they've had a hundred days in office
right now and this is the biggest crisis
they're dealing with
and they have failed to even acknowledge
there's a crisis they'll even come down
here to address it
until they come down here and see
exactly what's going on in the ground
see how porous the border actually is
see who
is coming across the border and how
dangerous they are they're not going to
solve the problem they need to come to
grips with the magnitude of the problem
and they need to step up and address it
well she said she's looking at the
root causes and she says the root cause
is poverty
what about the root cause of why they
decided now because under president
trump
we were seeing apprehensions at a
45-year low let's be clear
the root cause is lack of border
security
if they secure the border here's let's
step back
most americans and i'll put myself in
this class most americans
believe in illegal immigration and if
you believe in legal immigration you
need to
support enforcing the illegal
immigration laws
and it's the illegal immigration laws
that the body administration is
abandoning
and legal immigration we issue one
million green cards
every year coming up more of my
exclusive conversation with texas
governor greg abbott
open border is just one part of joe
biden's radical agenda we'll talk about
the rest of it when we come back
[Music]
welcome back we continue now with our
exclusive coverage the state of texas
has sued the biden administration
five times over its immigration policies
governor abbott has demanded the
administration
shut down at least one unaccompanied
minor facility in san antonio because of
allegations of abuse including
sexual assault taking place there watch
there were multiple concerns i had at
that facility candidly other facilities
that we
we've had in the state of texas there
were allegations
that were filed with two state agencies
uh in the state of texas
uh there was sexual assault taking place
uh with
very grotesque and very disturbing
allegations that were made
but these are not new people need to
understand this is not a
one-time type allegation allegations
like this have occurred over the years
and one reason why they do occur is
because you have an inadequate number of
personnel and staff overseeing it from
what i observed myself and going into
that facility
i saw no law enforcement i saw no
security whatsoever either inside
or outside that facility i've seen these
facilities
across the entire border region and then
none of them
have i seen any type of security to make
sure that
people would not be able to escape or
engage in other acts that could endanger
either people inside or outside of the
facilities
governor i want to move on to the
broader agenda the border policies or
lack of policies this one part of a what
has been a radical agenda
the democrats are pushing hr1 they're
pushing to get rid of the filibuster
they want to pack the supreme court
president biden says he's going to put a
commission together
what are you seeing from your standpoint
from the federal government in terms of
uh taking taking power away from the
states right
and you said it perfectly because now
what the bite administration wants to do
is completely redesign the united states
of america in a way that's contrary
to the constitution the united states
was designed so that each
state would be able to have its own
design texas is the perfect example
of why we need to have states be
different because texas ranks number one
in pretty much
every economic category have you seen a
big movement
in terms of people moving to texas right
no idea well it's one thing that
happened in the census
texas added more people over the past
decade than any other state
people are moving here right and left
however what happened this past year
the year of covet really accelerated all
of that
tell me about the lawsuits i mean texas
has been suing the federal government
for a number of reasons a number of
states have by the way but the excel
pipeline this is something i know that's
very important to you this was a real
growth story for texas and for the
country
well listen the excel pipeline is a
subset of a larger agenda for the bond
administration and that is to
crack down on fossil fuels and let me
tell you now he's hurting down here in
the polls because of that
it's one reason why president trump in
his re-election campaign did so well
in the rio grande valley yeah what about
the census got two more items to talk to
you about census and the covid
what's happening here in texas because
you're what you're open
for business obviously but we saw
changes in the in the census
and the republicans are looking at
investigating this
did you lose a congressional seat in
texas what happened with the census
numbers
i think an investigation does need to be
done and so
they need to do it very quickly because
the time clock on this is short but
if you look at all the numbers of many
red states
the initial assessment of the numbers of
what the population growth was
uh was reduced by the final numbers uh
and then other
blue states uh they were supposed to be
losing population
uh and suddenly they were not losing as
much as what had been
prognosticated and so there there is
something fishy
about the the final census results and
it's right that there be an
investigation and maybe even litigation
to clarify exactly what's going on who
who changed
the numbers why did they change it was
it a valid change
things like that
my thanks to texas governor greg abbott